c'est un Vancouver véritable porte sur
le continent asiatique que la ministre
des Affaires étrangères Mélanie Jolie a
annoncé officiellement la nouvelle
stratégie Indo-Pacifique du Canada notre
objectif est d'être non seulement ferme
mais de défendre nos intérêts nationaux
donc on ne sera jamais on n'aura jamais
à s'excuser pour défendre notre intérêt
national face à une Chine qui serait de
plus en plus perturbatrice à
l'international
Ottawa dépensera donc 2,3 milliards de
dollars en 5 ans pour entre autres
augmenter sa présence militaire et
navale dans la région et aussi tisser
des liens commerciaux plus forts avec
des pays comme l'Inde l'Indonésie le
Japon et la Corée du Sud on reconnaît
l'importance du reste de la région
Indo-Pacifique et on voit y consacrer
des ressources je dirais dans à peu près
tous les domaines importants tout comme
l'ex ambassadeur Guy Saint-Jacques
l'ancien diplomate de Jean-François
Lépine a été consulté par la ministre
Mélanie jolie on a évaluer cette région
là depuis longtemps on a vu le fait
qu'on est rebâti la stratégie canadienne
n'ont pas en fonction de la Chine mais
autour de la Chine c'est la première
fois effectivement que le gouvernement
canadien admet qu'il y a ce problème là
c'est à dire cette évolution de la Chine
un pouvoir autocratique et qui perturbe
les règles internationales pour la
prochaine décennie le Canada va donc
privilégier ces relations avec ces pays
amis et plus après la chute du mur de
Berlin on se rend compte on se rend
compte dans le monde avec ce qui est
arrivé en Ukraine qu'on va dorénavant de
voir coexister dans le monde avec des
puissances riches prospère comme la
Chine par exemple qui ne partagent pas
nécessairement nos valeurs même si on
compte encore coopérer avec la Chine sur
des questions globales comme la lutte
contre les changements climatiques ici
Gabriel prout Radio-Canada Montréal